what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
what's going on guys this is Rob and I
thought a pretty cool topic would be
like the powers of copycat from Deadpool
- I thought it'd be like a pretty cool
topic so so here's the deal
which by the way tomorrow's video for
those guys who were interested
tomorrow's video is the bat-family Civil
War from DC we were and then we're
probably like apparently it's full story
Fridays because that's what it is now so
we'll just do like the death and return
a Batman I don't know anyway um so yeah
so copycat all right here's a funny
thing bringing copycat in because
Vanessa Carlysle she was the girlfriend
of Deadpool in the first movie for those
of you guys who don't who don't know she
is um bringing her in to Deadpool - is
kind of intriguing and I'm actually
pretty interested to see what they do
because Vanessa Carlysle she made her
first appearance back in New Mutants
issue number 98 now here's a crazy thing
about this Vanessa Carlysle is
intriguing like her powers are actually
I think one of the coolest power sets in
Marvel Comics and here's here's the
reason why and Marvel you have like a
wide array of different powers right but
like to me no set of powers is more
interesting than people who can
shape-shift and become other people now
the most popular shapeshifter in Marvel
by virtue of the movies I would say is
mystique she's really the one that gets
like the most prominent there's other
shapeshifters around there too but
mystique is the one that gets like the
most you know the most screen town the
most FaceTime because you know she was
played by like Rebecca romaine and she
was played by Jennifer Lawrence and and
she really is like one of the more
popular characters out there but
Mystique's ability to shape-shift is
surface meaning that she can copy the
appearance of a person and that's it
that that's all she can do she can't
like you know shape-shift into
Nightcrawler and then teleport around
her powers don't work that way it's
really more of just a surface ability
it's just the restructuring of her
physical form with copycat it's not that
way
so copycat has the ability to
shape-shift into people and then copy
their powers and the reason why is it
goes all the way down to like this
cellular level as the exploration Marvel
games but remember when it comes to like
mutants and when it comes to any being
that has a superpower it's all based on
their genes right like that goes all the
way back to to stay it really the two
Jack Kirby his whole god what was what
was it that he wrote that in I keep on
to say it I think it was he Turtles I
keep want to say was he turtles but he
wrote that whole thing well the
celestial showed up in the early days of
man and they messed with the genes of
people
and you had the deviance and he had the
Eternals and then you had baseline
humans whose genes were modified so that
in some 10,000 years that basically like
the genes would start to kick in and
slowly but steadily hewed started
getting people with superpowers which is
worried we got Selene from like 10,000
years ago we got apocalypse we got
Gideon we got God who else did we get
well came the conquer was a time travel
time travel she isn't really count but
you got like the the like the various
externals that existed out there and
then you started getting into like the
Age of Heroes so like in the 1940s 1950s
1960s you started seeing like this huge
expansion of a mutant population his the
formation of the original x-men but like
that was this the whole basis behind
like how people get superpowers and so
it's all gene based for people like
Bruce Banner
it's a genetic destructure you know his
genes were irrevocably modified when he
was hit with the gamma bomb for Steve
Rogers it's a modification of his genes
by virtue of the Super Soldier Serum and
the various radiating already a
radioactive ray of radioactive waves
that he was exposed to for Peter Parker
is his genes he was bitten by a
radioactive spider that's part of his
genetic structure now it's always the
same way across the board with mutants
it's just the activation of an X gene
somewhere along the line that X gene
just kicks off usually that happens
under one of two circumstances it's
usually just puberty or it's duress
sometimes you have mutants born with
just like an insane amount of power
right like you had Hope Summers she was
the first mutant born after the events
of house of M when the Scarlet which
stripped 98% of the meetin's population
of their powers but she was born like in
immediately her powers kicked off it was
like holy cow like dude this chick is
insanely powerful like she's like the
most powerful force that you know
cerebro had picked up at the time which
Marvel does that a lot like I mean that
happened with Hope Summers that happened
with like the arrival of strife that
happened with what strife is awesome
that happened with like what was it with
Mathew Malloy I mean it happens all
those different things you know all the
time depending on how big of a deal
Marvel wants to make whatever mutant
they're introducing and so with with
Vanessa when she again copies someone
she copies them down to the DNA line
like down to the genes which means that
like she basically copies their powers
and so because of that like the the
other thing is when she copies people
because she's copying their DNA for
someone like Wolverine he can't really
tell the difference
like Wolverine picks up a difference by
sin right that's how you they usually
have like Wolverine discover that
like mystique been impersonating someone
this whole time because Wolverine just
like the nose nose you know but like
with with Vanessa Carlysle he can't
differentiate those things his sense of
smell is not keen enough to be able to
pick up the the minut differentiations
between like copycats DNA and and the
person she's that he's copying because
there still are strands of herself there
and so she doesn't lose herself whenever
she copies someone well as she did up
until X Factor I'm so I have until
weapon that when she joined Weapon X and
she tried it so it's this weird story is
this weird story she eventually leaves
like we'll talk about like her first
appearance here in a second but like she
eventually goes off and does her own
thing and then she ends up in X Factor
I'm sorry I'm Weapon X and then she
tries to bring Deadpool in and Deadpool
won't join there's another guy at the
same time as part of Weapon X named Kane
would you view all know who he is it
doesn't matter but like they they you
have Kane in the a Vanessa Carlysle
Vanessa Carlysle because of the fact
that Weapon X had like modified her
power so she could like pick up even
more steam when she was cloning people
she eventually started to lose her mind
or her memory or something like that
1990s comics and so like she ends up
going after Deadpool but then I think
like she falls in love with him and so
then what the next Sims came and then
Deadpool defeats Kane but then Vanessa
Carlysle was killed and that's like I
want to say it's like x-factor 58 or 59
or something like that I came in rock
top my it's been forever since I read
the old Rob Liefeld x-factor comics just
keep in mind guys I don't know
everything about everything so so it is
it is kind of cool now here's the deal
so when when Vanessa Carlysle first
showed up you would initially didn't
really know what she was about right
like one thing to bear in mind I want to
do a little bit of an explanation here
for those of you guys who were new in
Marvel Comics you have like a wide array
of different X Universe teams when I say
X universe I mean things that revolve in
some form or fashion around the x-men so
you've had you've had a whole bunch of
different teams you've had you had like
the original x-men by Stan Lee and Jack
Kirby you had uncanny x-men which is
like Wolverine and storm and Colossus
and all those guys you had x-factor
which was the original Stanley Jack
Kirby x-men forming their own team you
have x-force you have a lot of different
x-men teams that are there back in with
the uncanny x-men era when Chris
Claremont was writing it you had an
editor-in-chief of the time named Jim
shooter and Jim shooter said I want a
new
x-men team if you guys don't do this and
I will find someone else who will and
because they were the two like top x-men
you know X universe writers at the time
they basically banded together and they
formed a new mutants I'm pretty sure it
was and new mutants was launched by
Chris Claremont picked up by Louis by
Louise Simonson and she wrote it for
like the first eighty five issues or
something like that
eventually with issue number 86 she left
I think like Bob Harris the editor in
chief at the time kind of like forced
her out more or less and then Rob
Liefeld the creator of Deadpool came on
board so Rob laughs Rob Liefeld writes
from issues 86 up to issue number 100
and when Rob Liefeld took over instead
of having the New Mutants it's just kind
of like a team that was free-floating
because they basically were I mean New
Mutants had some cool stories you know
like with Danny moon star and all those
characters eventually Xavier left earth
to go hang out with the Shiar Empire to
be cure to some illness he had magneto
took over as leader of the team and then
Xavier came back magneto was was a went
back to being a villain and the new the
new mutants were just free-floating for
you know a couple of years and so Rob
Liefeld took it over and brought in
cable with like issue number 87 and said
cables gonna be the guy who like leads
the x-force or leads the the new mutants
team but the cool thing was that at the
time because of stories like The Dark
Knight Returns from DC Comics were
moving towards a direction of being like
more hardcore and like super high action
and you know all kinds of something like
darker grittier edgy stories and so Rob
Liefeld started moving the new mutants
in a direction to where they became more
militaristic and I want to say like
their first real evil team they faced
off against where that was the mutant
the Mutant Liberation Front
I think the mo MLF and I want to say it
was led by strife now if you guys don't
know who strife is strife is a demon
this guy is a absolute monster so strife
is basically what cable would be if he
wasn't held back right like if you guys
have seen the Deadpool trailer you guys
know that cable has like a robotic arm
and like he has an eye that glows
that's the techno-organic virus it's a
virus he was infected with as a baby by
the bone apocalypse to test and see
whether or not cable could be like a
host for apocalypse you know like a new
host body and so because of that cable
basically has to use his telepathy and
telekinesis to keep that virus from
literally eating him alive and then
turning him into a machine and then
eventually killing him ah strife doesn't
have that problem
strife there's a cloned version of cable
from the
future and so strife can just use its
telepathy and telekinesis for whatever
he wants to and he is stupidly powerful
he shut off the powers of Jean Grey I
don't think she had the Phoenix force at
the time but he shut off the power of
Jean Grey which is no easy feat that's
like shutting off the mental abilities
of Professor X I want to say in
execution her song which is an amazing
story an executioner song he went
against a full a full contingent of the
x-men x-force and x-factor all at the
same time and one I'm pretty I'm pretty
sure that's the case I'm not gonna swear
to it I'm gonna be kind of you know over
over glorifying it because I haven't
read the story in years but like it was
it was a really really cool it was a
really cool set of events he's Buber
powerful but anyway um so like like that
was their first real big thing and that
was like Rob Liefeld basically saying we
want to turn these guys and like a
pretty hardcore team we're gonna turn
them into like a pretty militaristic
team and it was huge oh dude it was huge
like it was it was crazy because of the
way that Rob Liefeld was writing New
Mutants by the time issue number 100 hit
which ended the New Mutants series and
then x-factor I'm sorry x-force number
one picked up the next month it was a
seamless transition I mean just because
of the way he was writing it the only
thing that changed was the name and so
because of that like my XIX verse number
one it's like the second highest selling
comic of all time I was a huge deal I
was a hugely I when I first came out
that story was massive I virtually had
dropped off a pretty sure when rifle run
Rob Liefeld left but still like it's it
was an amazing story like back way back
when it came out he was an amazing line
of comics so yeah like like Vanessa
Carlysle getting back on topic I have
this really terrible habit of like
diverting off-topic hopefully I did in
the way where I give you guys a whole
bunch of cool information but in any
event so new me ins number 98 hits two
issues before new memes ends an x-factor
or x-force number one picks up and
Vanessa Carlysle shows up all right now
the whole idea here was that Vanessa
Carlysle like like we didn't really know
what the deal was all we knew was that
with cable being so mysterious at the
time because you didn't really know
anything about him when he first showed
up with cable being so mysterious at the
time the idea was somewhere along the
line he fell in love with a girl named
Domino and she was like oh she was like
one that kind of helped him to do this
you know this whole superhero thing and
so because of that Domino seemed to have
gone missing but then like you suddenly
had Domino who was there
like okay cool I guess everything is fun
and so you wind up finding out later on
that's copycat and copycat is working
for a villain named mr. Tolliver who
later on you figure out is actually the
son of cable from the future who went
back in time to kill his dad but like
she's working for mr. Tolliver and she
ends up she's basically tasked by mr.
Tolliver
to go and to infiltrate dead I'm sorry
infiltrate a cables team now you don't
really get any backstory about Vanessa
Carlysle when she first popped up she's
just there and that's how comics wore
back then like back then characters were
just up here and then you would get an
origin story later on if they were
interesting which made sense it wouldn't
make any sense to like go through and
craft this huge elaborate origin for a
character if no one cared and so because
of that she's part of a part of New
Mutants for a little while and then I
want to say that like Deadpool shows
I've double shows up in the same comic
because Vanessa Carlysle had gone off
the reservation when she had gone
through and started infiltrating the
team she wasn't reporting back to mr.
Tolliver like she was supposed to and so
the result is that Deadpool figures out
like Deadpool's assigned by mr. Tolliver
to track down the Nessa Kyle and to
remind her of her mission and so she
ends up being like okay eventually she
reveals the truth to cable and his team
because she's you know has grown really
close to them and she's in love with
cable because I mean the guy's huge and
like he makes it he puts the rock to
shame because he's so muscular so I mean
I would probably fall in love with him
too but she ends up falling in love with
cable and and she basically like betrays
Tolliver so then you know Deadpool sent
in and Deadpool comes back and he ends
up facing off against the whole team he
fights cable which is kind of cool
and then from there Deadpool just like
appears sporadically eventually Vanessa
Carlysle stood the real Domino shows up
at the end of the story and that's the
end of that uh but but she's cool like
like I mean for her character like with
cable having telepathic and you know
telekinetic abilities albeit not on the
same level of strife still like his
powers are sufficient enough that he can
read minds and so if he goes through and
he reads the line of Vanessa Carlysle
and as far as he's aware like she is
basically Domino because she has all the
same memories she looks the same like
her genetic structures the same that's
how deep her powers go like that's not
significant her powers go now in terms
of how her powers are gonna work in a
movie I have no clue I'm assuming that
like Weapon X will give them to her
by some man in some manner or some means
because I I feel like it'd be kind of
weird to have her listed as copycat in
Deadpool two instead of just Vanessa
Carlysle and Deadpool
one though if they actually assign the
codename copycat then in some former
fashion she's gonna be she's gonna be
copycat now they could take like a
simpler approach and they could just say
well she's just a really good master of
disguise
you know maybe they do that I kind of
hope they don't like I kind of hope she
actually has a shape-shifting ability um
but again like it's it's cool like when
it comes to care just like that like
they're really they're not very well
known
they're pretty small-time like Vanessa
Carlysle she didn't appear in that many
comics I would say probably less than
200 and when you compare that to someone
like Wolverine who appeared in 12,000
it's night and day
and so what like like when you take
someone like her she's pretty well said
she's pretty unknown no one really knows
anything about her she's pretty obscure
except for outside of certain circles
namely like hardcore comic book readers
but her powers are so unique and so
powerful now I don't think they've ever
really tested like the upper limits
right like I don't think she's like
protege you know protege was basically a
character from an alternate universe who
could copy the powers of anyone he saw
up to and including like the Living
Tribunal so he was he basically became
like a multiversal threat overnight like
it was it was crazy how powerful he was
um she's not on that level but like
they've never had her face off against
like gladiator of the Shiar one of many
of Marvel's versions of Superman and
then like try to copy his powers like
they've never really done that or like
copy the powers of Franklin Richards or
like you know mad Jim Jasper's or
someone like like you know Michael court
or whatever live day they like she's
never never copied the powers of like an
extreme reality warper as far as I'm
aware but there's no reason to say she
couldn't if she copies their genes
there's no reason to say that she
wouldn't be able to pull it off so I
think she's like one of those kind of
sleeper characters I'm curious to see
what they do in comics after the movie
comes out depending on what happens in
the movie because Marvel Comics has a
really big history of like just kind of
capitalizing on on like a movie not
really getting a whole lot of thought to
the comic just saying here write a comic
about it and then they then they you
know they crank it out and usually it's
not very good but still like I mean
they'll probably end up you know
bolstering it up I have no clue but with
that being said guys really go ahead and
ring this video to an end ah if you are
new here two comments explain make sure
you guys hit the sub button to become
part of the rob4 if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
by the way the camera that I'm using
here is a Canon 1dx mark - a lot of you
guys have asked that question so anyway
we're gonna bring this video to an end
and that will catch you all later Bruce
[Music]
[Music]